thank you alejandro we are indeed with
another victor of today's round ellen
wang ellen welcome to st louis welcome
to the u.s junior girls championship how
does it feel to be here
um well yeah it's a big honor for me to
play in this tournament first of all
just because it is my first time and i
watched this tournament growing up and i
watched all of my role models like play
and win so yeah i'm really excited to be
here how did you prepare for this
tournament
um yeah so obviously opening preparation
is just like for every big tournament
looking up
the openings for each of my opponents
and just making sure my brain is sharp
with tactics and puzzles and whatnot and
also just relaxing making sure that i'm
well rested for the long two weeks ahead
well definitely a good start for you a
victory with the white pieces take us
through the critical moments of today's
game
yeah well i thought um she wasn't really
expecting the opening that i played and
then i was probably a little bit better
out of the opening just because i have a
little bit of extra space but
um i think i'm probably did you
anticipate the bononi from her or no i
thought um after like f3 in the same ish
i thought she would play like knight c6
instead of knight d7 yeah because that's
i think more of the main line but
um yeah i wasn't anticipating knight bd7
sorry to interrupt you there for a
second we do have a big result a
wanderer liang has lost his first game
in the juniors
as you can see justin wang still on the
board wonder bolted out of there wow i'm
sure he was unhappy
huge victory for justin wang let's keep
going
yeah i think yeah rook i played rook e1
and then rook a1 which
definitely was not the best um because
after queen a5 i think my a4 pawn was a
little bit under pressure
so i wasn't really sure how to defend it
at the moment
but it also felt like she was struggling
to find placement for her pieces
especially that knight on d7
so she went knight to f8
and let's keep going
yeah um and then here we were both i
think kind of getting into a little bit
of time pressure trying to make 40 moves
so
um
yeah i thought i was a little bit worse
here actually i'm not really sure why
but just i didn't feel like my position
was the greatest with the rook still on
a1 the queen like the two bishops still
kind of locked in
and then queen to f1 let's uh
were you expecting rook to e8 instead of
knight to g6 try to take more pieces off
the board yeah did you feel like she's
hinting at a potential rook to h8 and
try to create something on the h5
well i didn't before king g7 i didn't
think she would play that but then after
king g7 i knew that she was planning on
playing rick hey but yeah i was
definitely expecting ricky gate um
instead of the plan that she played
absolutely a5 very nice move knight to
d1
and despite the fact that she's creating
some mating threats there's no follow-up
yeah
um
i think yeah we were both just trying to
make moves honestly and not blunder but
yeah i think here this is where my
position started to get
better because
after queenie 2 bishop f7 and then 93
the knights going to c4 and i think 97
might have been a blunder
but we couldn't find any way in which
you could uh defend the d6 pawn even if
she goes knight to c8 you have knight
takes d66 after knight yeah yeah and
perhaps this is what she missed
because i think this was exactly the
40th move so yes
yes
ellen still a big result for you a nice
start with the white pieces who do you
have tomorrow do you know um yeah i'm
black against alice that's going to be
definitely a tough one have you guys met
uh yeah we talked a little bit yesterday
at the dinner in the opening ceremony
and yeah we're all we're all very
friendly off the board but definitely on
the board it's going to be a tough time
did you ever meet her on the board over
the board no i haven't
first one yeah
um yeah she'll definitely come with some
high preparation so i definitely need to
you know reciprocate that that's
definitely her style go get some rest
get some preparation going and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you oh
congratulations ellen indeed well done